all right here's what's on my radar
screen and we talked about this last
week as it related to the firing of amy
palsec the director of of pr formerly
with the houston texans and this it's
the jack easter bee conundrum in houston
a guy who was hired as the vp of player
development
became the executive vp of football
operations is now the interim general
manager
and there are lingering questions about
whether or not he truly has the
credentials for the job and whether or
not there is some
embellishment
exaggeration
and or fabrication
of past credentials that would boost
his qualifications for the current job
right and i've got layers of
concerns with this chris and i've tried
to organize it in my brain whether it
comes out
as organized is a different issue
altogether i'm concerned that number one
and let me start with the basic problem
because when i was growing up a very
long time ago and when i was in college
and you know
it was drilled into me
you never
take liberties with your resume
because number one they're eventually
going to find out
and number two if there's any
ambiguity
someone is going to ask questions and if
you are puffing in any way
it's it's a cardinal sin you don't lie
about your experiences you don't
exaggerate your experiences and
look i don't know that jack easterby has
intentionally and affirmatively lied
about his experience to help get the job
that he now has but there's questions
out there that have not properly been
asked or answered or drilled down upon
from his characterization of his
experience with the jaguars in 2004
when his online bio with the texans
previously said he was the assistant to
director of football operations and then
at some point after i started asking
questions about that to people in the
league who know him
it changes
it gets cleaned up and then i asked the
texans when was it cleaned up and why
was it cleaned up and frankly
their official statement is not
factually accurate as to when it was
cleaned up because they said it was
cleaned up a year ago and i know for a
fact that the thing that rose or gave
rise to the question was there in march
of this year little things like that
when will that be explored does anyone
care why doesn't anyone care why isn't
anyone bothered by the possibility that
there was overstatement of the
background of this person who holds a
very important job with one of the 32
nfl franchises and there's more let me
just mention the two others yeah and and
this one this one to me
is genius
the impression has been created that
jackie used to be worked for the chiefs
for two years he didn't work for the
chiefs he never worked for the chiefs he
was never paid by the chiefs he provided
free services to the chiefs they paid
for his travel
to and from kansas city on the weekends
but at the time he was working for
newbury college in one of the carolinas
i think south carolina as an assistant
athletic director here's the genius
his time with newbury college is never
mentioned his time working there is
never mentioned in his texans online bio
because what that would potentially do
is cause someone to realize he didn't
actually work for the chiefs right so
you sacrifice your your experience with
newberry as an assistant a.d so you
don't undermine the perception that you
actually work for the chiefs when you
didn't work for the chiefs now he did
work for the patriots but not in a
personnel capacity and bill belichick
earlier this week
asked the question by houston media
because the patriots and texans play
each other this week belichick said he's
not a personnel person right which look
it's a big deal in houston because the
team stinks i think if the team was good
nobody in houston would care but my
understanding is the houston media is
talking about houston fans are upset
about it and and i i don't think it's
because of the right thing to do or any
of these issues it's because the team
stinks and he's identified with one of
the reasons why the team stinks because
he's identified with the trades that
have helped make the team stink chris so
i don't know that the people who are up
in arms about jack east to be in houston
are up in arms for the reasons they
should be here's why it bothers me it
bothers me because
you've got somebody who potentially is
not qualified to hold a lucrative job an
important job a powerful job an
influential job with an nfl team there
aren't many of those jobs out there
there are plenty of qualified people
people far more qualified than jack
eastwood he's taking a spot that someone
else should have that someone with
better qualifications real
qualifications to be an executive vp of
football operations an interim general
manager should have and at a time when
the nfl is doing everything it can to
promote and expand minority
opportunities at the highest levels of
the sport
should it not be troubling
that
there probably are many
minority executives with nfl teams who
have infinitely more qualifications than
jack easterby who should have the job
that he currently has that's the problem
so even if we
set aside
the questions that are unanswered
regarding whether or not he actually
engaged in resume embellishment there's
one more that i didn't mention the
greatest champion foundation a
non-profit that he's part of had on its
website before it went down for
maintenance a claim that he's been
entrusted with dozens of head coaching
searches for major universities and
mid-major universities dozens and then
they changed to say more than 50 before
they pulled the plug on the website the
guy's been out of college for 15 years
how are you entrusted with over 50 head
coaching searches that's a question that
needs to be answered so my ultimate
point is this
regardless of whether or not there's
irregularities and i think there are
irregularities that need to be addressed
this is somebody who when you
objectively look at his qualifications
chris
he should not be in the job that he's in
definitely and there are other people
out there in the football business who
deserve to be in that job and that's
what's fundamentally wrong with this
picture yeah i i mean agreed i mean
everything you you said agreed
especially you know the aspect of you
know yeah it seems like he's
for lack of a better way to say it
conned his way into this position that
he's in specifically right now and not
to say he's not qualified to
work in an organization i mean obviously
there was something that bill belichick
and billy o'brien liked about him to
want him to be there that felt like he
was qualified in some capacity
but there's no way is this what he's
doing right now and it is ridiculous
especially with the issues of minority
hiring and the fact that we don't have
more people of color in those power
positions and now we're going to let
this guy who yeah it certainly seems
like he fabricated you know
his his uh we don't know wait wait it
hasn't needs to be invented
i'm just saying at eye level right now
topical it just seems that way yeah we
don't know um but my my internal my
internal crap filter is is uh is is is
engaged it's it's always something that
doesn't smell right here it's a weird
thought about him around football
listen there's a faction of people that
like him
and hey yeah jack's great and blah blah
blah i don't really ever hear what he's
great at okay so and again i don't know
him so i'm trying not to be a jerk or
anything like that but
i also within that small faction of that
likes him
you know there's also another group out
there that
i get texts from people around the nfl
mike all the time when you start talking
about this because they're happy you're
bringing light to this i think there's a
lot of people in football that think
again for lack of a better way to say it
think he's a fugazi and nobody's calling
it out and they love that you are so
well and let me say this this is the
other thing that bothers me right
because i hear from people too and i
hear from people in the media not local
media national media and there are
people in national media who refuse to
address it because they want to preserve
their access to jack easter be see he
can be a very useful ally he can provide
you with information about the texans so
these people who make their living
giving us a five minute heads up before
something gets announced by a team they
don't want to piss jack each to be off
because he's a golden one of their
various golden geese
i don't care about that stuff i care
about what i think is right and what i
don't think is right and i think there's
something here that isn't right on
various levels and uh i'm not i'm not
afraid to say so chris so i and i and it
bothers me that it's not a bigger deal
yeah i i understand i mean it's it's a
very high important position in the
organization and we don't really know
the qualification qualifications of the
guy or how he got there and does he
really deserve it it's wrong
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports